VOTED TONT
DONALD TRUMP AFTER THE JANUARY
6tINSURRECTION, ALL ARE FACING
CENSURE.
TRUMP, STATED SIGNATURESFOR ADDG
CENSURED FIVE.
AS OTHERS, CAN
G 10 INCLUDING MWSLAZ CHENEYF H.
WYOMING THAT W
BY THEIR STATES.
ROF OUR ESCAPED SI
BUT EVEN A V
UTAHEPOTO CONVICT FORMER
DONALD TRUMP I OF HIS
IMPEACHMENT
DAYS?AT DO YNKF IDENT BIDEN'S F0
>> THERE WERE ACLY CHEERS
FOR ROMNEY B BOOs WERE
ING AT TIMES.
>> Y AS A PERS
SAYS WHAT HE THINKS AND
HIDE THE FACT THAT IT FAN OF OU
CHARACTEIS[ BOO ]
YOU MAY CALL ME AN OLD FASHIONE.
I
OH.U CAN YOU WANT.
BUI'VE BEEN AN ALL
I S A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT IN>> SE REPUBLICANS S
COMMUNIST AT ROMNE THE END, THET
M FAED.
TES.
A SLIMVOTEONRESOLUTION THAT SAI
SHOULDN'T HAVE VH
TR THAT DONALD
TRUMP'S 2019 CALL TO THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT WHREEN
TOD UP FOREIGN AID WASPEECY OKA.
TRUMP, FAR FROM INSIGH
RIOTS URGED FOLLOWERE
YOUR VOICEHEARD..
DON'T FIGHT LIKE HELL, YOU'R
NOT GOING TO HE A COUNTRY
>> YOU KNOW, N SO LONG AGOYMOUS
WITH UTA FRY SAUCE AND T  ELECT
STATE WITH 73% OF THE VOTE.
T YOUROM
PRESIDENT OF
>> MY HOW TIMES HAVE CHANGED.
THIS WAS THE SCENEN E
AT THE AIRPORT AS ROMNEY
ELECTOCOLLEGE RESULTS. TAI
A JOKE
ABTEE.
US>> REPUBLICANS LIKE MITT ROMNE
UT HOME OF EECIES.RHAPTH'S
DINOSAUR NATIONAL MONUMENT WHICH
MAY FEATURE REPUBLICANS THAT SCH
OTRSAS FHE
S
TOE CIRCULAR FIRING OTN ABLE
SQUAD.
AFFILIATES ARE TAKING THEM T
WAYS INCLUDING A
PASSED THAT READS  BREAKUP
LETTER TELLING NEB
JOB.LICAN SENATOR THAT HE IS
AND THERE WAS Y THROWN  WHERE
0 GUPARTY VICE CHAIRMAN INCRT
LIKEHIS, "NOBODY DEFENDED
AB
HIM".
THIS WAS AN VEO NICE
THINGS ABOUT HIM.
THOUGH IT HAPPENS TO BE THE
FR FAMILY ANKINSINGER GOTHURES I
CONGRESSMAN FRICHI
BY CENSURES FROMHR
WHEN TFAO HAVE.
ONE OF THEED HIMR SER